bonjour quel a été votre sentiment en
découvrant ces images de la cathédrale
en feu hier en premier c'est un choc
bien sûr comme toujours chaque fois
qu'il ya un déficit de ce type du type
d'une cathédrale où un monument un
monument de cette envergure c'est
toujours un choc et une grande tristesse
puisque ce sont des notre patrimoine qui
est touché au coeur la piste criminelle
est privilégiée aujourd'hui comment
expliquer ces trois départs de feu là on
le rappelle au niveau du grand orgue et
deux autres de part et d'autre de la nef
alors il est très difficile de me mettre
beaucoup de si et puis dans les conflits
quand on veut mais pour l'instant il
faut vraiment attendre les résultats de
l'enquêté
il ya eu trois départs de feu distincts
c'est ce qu'il y a c'est ce qui a fait
ouvrir automatiquement une enquête jours
comment un sur dix volontaires
maintenant il faut voir si ces trois
départs de feu qui ont eu lieu il y en a
un qui est à proximité d'un placard
électrique et l'autre qui relie un orgue
électrique et le troisième qui laisse au
niveau de l'ordre lui même qui est
également relié par les cultes et il va
falloir une enquête pour voir si c était
volontairement et csc trois foyers en
fait ont été volontairement allumé par
quelqu'un intentionnellement ou s'il n'y
a pas eu aucune connexion électrique est
possible aussi elle les persos sont
inestimables dans le grand orgue
derrière du xvième siècle et le tableau
d'hippolyte flandrin du 19e notamment
qu'elle était la valeur financière et
history de ses biens alors ce sont des
biens qu'ils sont irremplaçables certes
le tableau de famille de flandre a un
qui était avec est un tableau qui ne
pourront pas être reproduit de toute
façon et le grand-angle lui-même qui qui
a été qu'ils avaient été en plus ce qui
est acquis avec y avait plus de quatre
siècles et qui est opus avait été
restauré amélioré à plusieurs époques
lui même pourra jamais être être
remplacé donc c'est une perte
inestimable pour la région et pour le
port le pays pour le pur également pour
les pour les musiciens d'ailleurs qu'ils
utilisaient de cet orgue qui était l'un
des plus beaux de france est en première
instance qu'il faudra selon vous pour
réhabiliter les mécanos la cathédrale et
combien ce que cela pourrait coûter ça
c'est très difficile de le savoir et je
je me garderai bien de donner des dates
d'ailleurs le premier ministre qui a été
interviewé sur place sans le savez bien
gardé de faire la même chose qui avait
fait notre président d'ailleurs il y a
lors de l'incendié de notre dame qui
s'était un peu avancé a parlé de 4 5 ans
il s'est avéré en fait que le temps sera
beaucoup plus long donc ça prend
toujours du temps parce que d'abord il
ya une enquête et puis ensuite il va
falloir faire un diagnostic complet de
la structure il ya des pierres quand
même qui par la chaleur ont éclaté donc
il va peut-être y avoir des réflexions à
faire au niveau de la structure elle
même au niveau 2 au niveau des pierres
et même au delà du simple fait qu'ils
aient des parties combustible dont on
voit qu'ils aient pris ce qu'il ya un
problème aussi aujourd'hui selon vous en
ce qui concerne l'entretien de ces
cathédrales mais plus largement des
monuments
historiques et qui font partie de notre
patrimoine vous le rappeliez oui
certainement
il est certain il y a il y à certains
problèmes au niveau de la sécurité la
sécurisation de ces édifices publics
ceci dit le cas de nantes est très
particulier puisque c'était peut-être
l'une des cathédrales qui étaient les
plus protégés contre l' incendie puisque
c'est une cathédrale où il y avait déjà
eu un incendie en 1972 et qui avait été
refaite justement pour pouvoir résister
à d'éventuels futurs des as de ce type
donc c'est vraiment malheureux ce qui
est arrivé et parce que en plus toutes
là toute la charpente qui habituellement
est en bois sur ces cathédrales avait
été refaite principalement en béton est
compartimentée d'ailleurs pour éviter
qu'ils ne propagent érection deux
incendies donc cette cathédrale et est
l'une des mieux protégés
et c'est pourtant elle des éléments ou
rouler l'intérieur qu'est ce qui est
fait aujourd'hui pour mettre aux normes
notamment aux normes sécuritaires ce
type de monuments on a évidemment tous
en tête l'image de notre dame de paris
qui a chamboulé qui l'a beaucoup marqué
les esprits est ce que depuis via
quelque chose ou qui a été mise en place
justement pour ça ne se produise plus
ailleurs alors mise en place non il ya
eu beaucoup de il ya eu beaucoup de
réflexions que tu es mené mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas grand chose de
mise en place il faut savoir qu'en
france depuis plus d'une vingtaine
d'années
c'est pas le gouvernement actuel c'est
ça de sadate ça date pas d'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que les budgets ont été
considérablement réduits en ce qui
concerne l'équipement des édifices
publics de ce type qui appartiennent à
l'état
il faut pas l'oublier c'est sur les un
peu plus de 150 cathédrale qu'il ya en
france 87 sont propriété de l'état donc
c'est à l'état de les gérer c'est à
l'état de les équiper et il est vrai
qu'il ya eu de faire des choix
politiques et des choix et des choix de
priorités d
des budgets qui ont été considérablement
réduits ce qui fait que les cathédrales
demande d'équipement il n'y a pas de
surveillance incendie dans l'état dans
beaucoup de cas il n'y a pas de de
vidéosurveillance par exemple comme
certains ont émis quoique la
vidéosurveillance faut s'en méfier pour
les pour les effractions éventuel parce
que il ya une politique aussi liés au si
elle commet l usage qu on a en france de
ces édifices qui sont censés être ouvert
au public et gratuit donc le beaucoup de
gens sont plus ou moins contre le fait
d'avoir des caméras de surveillance un
peu partout mais par contre d'un point
de vue technique il y a beaucoup de
choses à faire il ya beaucoup
d'équipements à comment à placer dans
ces édifices
et puis il ya des travaux de mise aux
normes qui devrait être effective et
particulièrement sur les sur les
systèmes électriques / sur le fait dit
ni fugier certaines parties qui sont
sensibles aux incendies etc qui reste à
faire merci beaucoup d'argent à présent
de répondre à nos questions boris savez
les hs architecte spécialiste des
questions des risques majeurs